hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner again today we
have some interesting news to talk about
some upcoming balance changes that the
team has been working on some other
things besides that like the weekly
content and everyone's favorite Park the
road map of the month so as always like
the V fee do enjoy a subscriber for new
icon for the informational site a
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates the patch notes and the
leaks so if you never want to miss
enough they definitely stay tuned to the
channel Twitter and discord links if you
want to join those will be in the
description let's get started first up
is the road map and there isn't a lot
really it's just your standard weekly
content and weekly arcade and loot fest
but on March 14th to March 28th we do
have the release date for the new event
that's coming out this season as for
details we don't know anything yet we
will most likely know everything on
March 14th the day it releases so don't
worry I'll keep everyone up to date on
what's going to be going on within that
so definitely stay tuned to the channel
on that day for one we kept update with
that the new content of the week is
gonna be called the penguin walk and
honestly I can't believe this is
actually a thing it's pretty great I'm
definitely gonna be getting this for one
of my characters and it makes a little
penguin noise too as well I think it's
like seven thousand five thousand steal
whatever your basic emote would cost so
definitely want to grab that if you do
enjoy it and lastly we have the upcoming
balance they basically had a Q&A session
people from the stream and past posts
basically asked questions and they
answered those with their responses the
recent buff to dodging iframes wasn't
actually intended so this may be
reverted back if you've experienced this
they're trying to not nerf offence and
instead encouraged it because before it
was always about playing it safe pairing
and playing defense way back in the
beginning of year one of the game next
up was dodge block and this is most
notable on Ken's AT&T and black prior
they met this may be changed to a 100
millisecond startup so that the guard
doesn't switch immediately to that side
so it's going to be dodge 100
milliseconds then the guard will appear
on that side whatever whatever direction
you happen to be dodging in this is
basically to prevent people from getting
beaten on combos as opposed to the
opposing player so I'm really glad
they're going to be adding that just to
keep everyone else in line with everyone
this one and personally my favorite just
might be a little biased though they are
considering extending the guard of
gladiator to make it normal to other
assassins so thank you so much you be
for finally deciding to do this it's
been a hell of a time for anyone that
doesn't know gladiators guard is very
bad it is the fastest in the game that
goes by instantly a Centurion charged
heavy Highlander top heavy Raider top
heavy even maybe a side heavy and all of
Nicias heavies and many more cannot be
blocked on reaction from this guard
because of how slow those moves are so
you have to double back or just block
later in the move so it all depends on
how you play but they're very it's a
very big pain in the ass when you're
playing and then lastly they also want
to be working on bashes by halting their
stamina and not draining it when you're
in an out of stamina state so it's not a
constant cycle of going out of stamina
getting bashed lowering your stamina
even though you're already out of
stamina and keeping you in that scenario
for the entire fight you can't do
anything so they're gonna be working on
that trying to get looking at other
characters bashes see what's gonna be
useful for that and hopefully get some
feedback on us later in a couple weeks
hey guys is gonna be the enemy boots I
hopefully you guys did enjoy nothing too
crazy this week we did get a road map
and I'm very excited for March 14th I
mean don't you guys think the event is
possibly gonna be maybe we'll get a
teaser next week showing it off but who
knows we might not we might do I'll see
how that goes I'm very excited to see
how this goes I hopefully they add
something like totally new to the game
that we've never seen I think that'd be
really sweet showing off some new
content that we could possibly unlock in
the future kind of like how we had
signatures from marching fire and as
well the question I want to pass off to
you guys as far as for upcoming balance
changes what do you guys think that they
should add to the game that would
benefit it like what change should be
made now these are just hypotheticals
that I'm giving as an example but should
you go get rid of his hyper armor on
certain moves is it too much and black
prior not be bashing should our mu
should be a little bit faster stuff like
that I left another thoughts in the
comments below about personal balance
changes that you would make to the game
and that guys like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe for a new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being balanced changes here are updates
patch notes and leaks so if you do want
to be covered and off today with
everything happening in the world of
foreigner definitely stay subscribe to
the channel and that guys my two most
recent videos will be on screen you guys
want to check that out guys okay
yesterday big parts in the video and
peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]